here we go again against petit oh priya
we have a little bit of a discussion in
the bank oh I have not yet managed to
look this up so I get into trouble
against him in this line which I feel
should not happen again I'm not
believing that this is terrible for why
do anything I just feel I get into some
trouble and they don't know exactly why
I do it's this night a for business do
you have to do it differently somehow
and that's good he place that extremely
early this this idea very strange so AF
we have you had this on the board more
than once and somehow I didn't get a
good position and I don't understand why
maybe I have to go at five like really
punish him trying to punish him for his
for not developing I mean it's not move
that I particularly love to play because
it's such a it weakens so much we can
smell his but this is a dynamic option
and this makes some sense considering
again that he has not so much time so 94
probably not
not clear I can't take this I dont still
I'm not easily getting rid of this here
so it would be nice if I could just
trade it having a look at this pawn very
very unconventional position I cannot
easily play 94 as a success hanging
okay tries to activate it like this okay
I cannot play the queen of eight this
one maybe get active maybe I can place
for in this position somehow
I don't know and at least I think he
cannot easily play the bishop as b-2s
detect Queen f8 could be possible 97
though okay so what is he doing him to
playing for before maybe
[Music]
Queen f8 he has 97 unfortunately the
thing i would like to play for Shuang ok
see if I can go wherever it's not ideal
but ok so if I take it it shouldn't be
so bad
if it takes with the Queen I have 94
just just to activity I mean his night
I'll be six is not looking great
politics i can just take everyone and be
okay i think but maybe I can also do
more check try and hold f8 I just gotta
do graph to though yeah okay I can't go
okay wait then it doesn't really doesn't
feel critical
[Music]
it's got a week back rank here don't see
however some way to exploit it easily
Lucas hanging so he probably has to
trade just then I don't know those both
captures made sense okay check here I
know then I clennie can actually take
home time morning
see how I can enter with my bolkiah
that's very weird I actually go to have
sound not here 30 seconds okay at least
I'm attacking the c-4 pawns not easy for
amateur get this get this moving this is
rook a me non 0
man wandering East 7 god damn it it's
not that terrible actually but it was
chattin in 10 it wasn't intended at all
Jesus check check
check nine seconds check check not yes
black resins Jim hmm nah I mean I don't
have a syllable plus coy against the sky
and i mean and i keep getting good
positions but i don't don't don't don't
convert them this was definitely not bad
for black check this ending is totally
fine of course the Queen f 1 is minus a
million okay justice what now this for
Queen Anne farooq I've wanted made and
it can take here it's probably nothing
here just just meaningless chicks it
kind of felt wrong to me but I like to I
like the ending even now Queen you have
to have seven is good and this ending I
should also not lose but I'm down on
down on time I just landed a couple of
things yeah of course I can take the
five but I simply did not see that is
heaven hangs I thought 95 would just
draw but this is the chasm a better of
course chatons didn't see id seven wats
hand check and this is a draw i think
that check and cannot hold it with 15
seconds check that didn't didn't try all
the heart yeah he it might be losing
which ah so Queen f11 suppose a good one
huh ok thanks for watching